c'est une obligation vaccinale un vaccin
ou c'est un abonnement à des injections
successives tous les quatre mois mais
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure vous
avez dit que vous mettiez en place le
pass vaccinale pour protéger l'hôpital
mais c'est de vous qu'il faut protéger
l'hôpital
[Musique]
je fais partie de celles et ceux qui
pensent que la vaccination est
nécessaire et indispensable et je fais
aussi partie de celles qui pensent que
cela ne peut pas se faire quoi qu'il en
coûte au prix d'une telle fracturation
la société d'une telle stigmatisation
des personnes non vaccinées
[Musique]
en 2017 vous avez fermé 4900 lit en 2018
quatre mille deux cents lits en 2019
3100 lit en 2020 cette 5700 lui permet
vous battiez votre record dans le lit
fermé en pleine année qu'au lieu en mars
2020 il y avait cinq mille cinq cents
lits de réanimation en décembre 2021
après la crise il ya moins de lits vous
avez pas se fait passer encore malgré
vos beaux discours l'argent avant les
gens l'intégralité des mesures qui
restreignent les libertés individuelles
on est quand même obligé d'admettre ça
vous ne pouvez 4 mètres cela ne sont
liées au manque de lits dans les
hôpitaux français
[Musique]
boire ou manger dans les trains vous
vous rappelez tous de cette discussion
sur ces bancs le ministre olivier
verrons nous a répondu que nous avions
mal compris que évidemment nous
pourrions manger dans les trains 20h17
le ministre du baril annonce qu'il sera
possible de boire ou de manger dans les
trains en cas de besoin impératif quand
on vous dit que votre texte est absurde
deux ministres ne sont même pas capables
quand on parle
de manger
d'être d'accord on voit bien que il y a
pas ce que vous l'aviez déjà refusé la
présidente fois sur le pass annie terre
une volonté pour le gouvernement de
faire de ces outils là non pas un outil
de lutte contre l'épidémie sur des bases
scientifiques concrètes réel mesurable
mais bien un instrument de contrôle
social
[Musique]